The joe rogan experience.
Mike Tyson's a scene in the movie?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he's in it.
Yo,
when's that coming out?
Cause that you guys from that last year or two years ago?
Two years ago.
What it all my auntie.
Yeah,
but I don't,
I don't know when it's coming out because that dude Jimmy Henchman,
I took the shot,
Kevin,
I told him we was coming down in Miami.
He said he's going to do a screening.
Oh,
okay.
One of the producers got,
you know,
put,
put away.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
What's the wonderful other movies,
you know what I mean?
We can move on to the world,
man.
Movies.
Finding me at my best.
My best friend was the fact that I had a chance to work with Mike.
I knew Mike Tyson before he was the champ.
You know what I'm saying?
So I seen that the whole journey from the guy who was a regular dude that was
scared and he owed all these people were around him and tell him you could do
this.
And he did it and he became as bigger than life person all the way to the,
to the end.
Now the person that he is now,
because if you see Mike now,
Mike got his shit together.
You know what I'm saying?
He's not,
nobody could say,
oh,
he's outta control.
He's not out of control.
He's a married Dewey,
he's calm,
he's polite to people.
He doesn't get in trouble no more laughing,
dude man.
Interesting.
Yeah,
he got his shit together now.
So I feel good about that.
You know,
I got to work with him in that movie.
So that was a good feeling man.
Cause I hadn't seen him in years.
I seen him when I did see him,
he was back.
You know what I'm saying?
You've seen that documentary.
They,
I seen the document.
How fucking powerful was out with the parents.
We never seen that Tyson document.
Is it just called Tyson?
You see a man cry and cry when he reflects on parts of his life.
Strong man like that.
You have to realize that whatever was on it was no joke.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
That's a man who,
one time I went to his house and it was five or six limos and everybody would
get out the limo and I said,
I come to mass getting out the car.
They said,
hey,
you don't see that line standing over there.
Mike tasting in the lane and his front yard like hang over starts the only man
whose house I went over there was a lane in the front yard,
loose.
He was on the steps like this heavy weight belt.
He was like,
no man,
no,
that's not a cat.
That's a lion.
That's fucking real tasting in a lane.
The main line in his front yard,
loose shit.
It was walking.
It was off the leash,
man.
He was not in a cake.
It was in the yard.
Oh my God.
They came out and started wrestling with him.
God Damn.
So how big was the lion?
It was big man.
It was a line man.
He was wrestling with a lung over there and grabbed him and started tussling
with them and all the Shih tzus and everybody was in the limits to the land
could come up to a limousine and busted the window open and come in there.
I'm sorry.
Easy.
He could just go like get booth from come right in there and just having,
so everybody who was in the car you couldn't back out cause it was all like five
limos.
Everybody's in the car.
Her bad thinking it makes us getting me to be eaten by this lane but that isn't
happy is he plays with them and he put takes him in the back.
That comes back out and I was like,
you know what,
I'm never going to be in around another man in life that's going to do that.
And if you know what I'm saying cause to me he was it Mike Tyson,
is that a line team?
Give everybody making working in Vegas?
No,
he's just tame lanes.
He had one in his front yard.
He had other cats there to Bieber would never have a lion and it'd be like to
chills all the way or something.
Boys,
I can come and get this waiting and my cats.
Isn't that cause we've seen wild kingdom like make you've seen him eat
Willdabeast Tyson story is such a classic fucking story to him and goes from
being poor to being intensely rich intentionally.
Rick,
the,
the focus of attention of literally every person on the planet when he was at
his peak in the late eighties,
God,
when he beat Michael Spinks crazy.
Jesus Christ.
I don't even think people today when he had the billboard on Sunday and make
miss faces,
made an earn that,
that billboard strongest billboard on sensing.
It's an iron man.
Like his face was made the angel just Max face.
Awesome.
Uh,
building the years like the Bruce Seldon years where Bruce Seldon,
he didn't even like he missed him with a left talking cell.
Does knees buckle?
He got up and just said,
what am I doing getting up?
You know what?
I'm just knew better.
He knew all those guys was a destroyer.
There's no fighter out there right now.
I think that has captured the attention since since him not like him,
not like him since him.
Okay.